I'm Emily real and I'm a mathematician
I've been challenged to explain the
concept of infinity at five levels of
increasing complexity
so while the concept of infinity can
seem mysterious and it's very difficult
to find Infinity in the real world
mathematicians have developed ways to
reason very precisely about the strange
properties of infinity
[Music]
so what do you know about Infinity I
think it means that it's
something that's infinite that never
ends that's a great way to think about
it Infinity is something that never ends
we're finite the opposite of infinity
refers to a process or a quantity that
we could actually count all the way
through at least in theory if given
enough time
so if you had to guess
how many Skittles are in this jar
I would say about like 217. 217. and if
we wanted to figure out the exact number
how would we find out we could like put
them along divide them into pieces of
five and then we could use that yeah
absolutely in fact I did that before you
got here and it's uh 649 Skittles here's
a much harder question
how many pieces of glitter do you think
are in that jar maybe like 4012 I'll
admit I have absolutely no idea do you
think it's a finite number or an
infinite number finite because I can see
them all in here yeah you can see them
all and in fact if we were really really
really patient we could do the same
thing with this as with the Skittles but
here's another question you said that
there's a finite amount of glitter in
that jar and I agree so how many jars
would we need to hold an infinite amount
of glitter
and then if you're amount of jars very
good why do you say that because if
there's unlimited pieces of glitter we
need unlimited pieces of Jar so let's
try and imagine infinitely many jars
would they fit in this room
yeah no yeah absolutely not because this
room holds only a finite
amount of space and in fact infinitely
many jars would not even fit in
something called the observable universe
which is the
uh portion of the universe that
astronomers can see really how does that
make you feel
I actually feel like my brain is
exploding
that makes me feel like my brain is
that's a wonderful question a very rich
question what do you think I think maybe
because as you said it was unlimited you
have very good intuition so there are
ways that mathematicians can build
infinite collections of things and if
you repeat those processes it's in fact
possible to build even bigger and bigger
sizes of infinity so what have you
learned today about Infinity I've
learned that even if it's unlimited
there are many different ways of making
infinity and you can never actually see
it all
what does infinity mean to you really
anything that has no end to it yeah
that's absolutely right so Infinity gets
used a lot of different ways in
mathematics there's a way that
mathematicians think of infinity as a
number just like the number 13 just like
the number 10 million so wow okay so the
reason that mathematicians consider
Infinity to be a number is that it is a
size of a set so the first example of an
infinite set in mathematics is the set
of all county numbers so one two three
four five six seven Etc that list goes
on forever that is an infinite set and
to be a little bit more precise it's a
countably infinite set but as a number
infinity is pretty strange like what do
you mean by that adding Infinities
multiplying Infinities and there's a
sense in which it's very similar to the
arithmetic that you learned about
already but it's also totally different
it has some very weird properties
welcome to Hilbert's Hotel unlike in
order ordinary hotel has countably
infinitely many rooms suppose a new
guest shows up you might think that the
new guest could take the room that's all
the way down at the end of the hall all
the way
except there isn't a room like that the
rooms each have a number and even though
there's infinitely many rooms each room
is only a finite distance away so here's
how we're going to make room for the new
guest I'm going to ask the guest in room
one to move into room two
and then we're going to ask the guest in
room two to move into room three
and we'll continue this all the way
along it looks to me like there's space
for the new guest where is it it'll be
room number one room number one exactly
I'm going to use this symbol for
infinity but what we've just shown is
that one
the one new guest
plus infinity is equal to the same
Infinity
what happens if we add a second guest
would it be two plus infinity equals
infinity absolutely
okay so now I'm going to make this story
a little more complex but there's
another Hilbert's Hotel down the street
and they're having plumbing issues and
we need to find room for them okay they
can't live together they can't live here
that would be a great solution
I don't know I think these people don't
really get along so I need to somehow
create
infinitely many new rooms but I can only
ask each person in the hotel to move a
finite distance away right so let's take
the guest who is originally in room one
and move them into room two
so that's creating one new space for us
and now I'm going to take the guest who
was originally in room two and move them
into room four are you starting to see a
pattern here yes you're going up one
each time yeah I'm increasing by one
more each time so I'm doubling the room
number right so this is some of the
strange arithmetic of infinity so we
have two Hilbert hotels Each of which
have infinitely many guests right then
this is equal to
infinity infinity great
Hilbert's hotel is a story that
mathematicians have been telling
themselves for almost 100 years because
it's a really visceral way to think
about some of the counter-intuitive
properties of the arithmetic of infinity
how does Infinity come across in
mathematics for you so when I'm teaching
calculus and talking about Concepts like
limits and derivatives those are only
defined precisely with infinity teaching
algebra which is meant in a different
sense about number systems we deal with
infinite families of numbers and their
operations infinite sets are somehow
very exotic they're not found so
commonly in the real world but they're
all over mathematics
[Music]
what do you know about Infinity a
property of something being endless
great so today we're going to focus on
Infinity as a cardinality and what
cardinality means is it's a size of a
set what are you studying I'm studying
computer science studying computer
science are you taking any math courses
right now yeah right now I'm taking
calculus 2. calculus involves the study
of functions functions are one of the
most fundamental concepts in mathematics
but they aren't always so clearly
defined what would you say a function is
I would say a function is a procedure
that takes an input and does some
operation and returns an output that's
the computer science brain thinking
right there so we want to think of a
function as a procedure or a mapping
between sets so a function defines a
one-to-one correspondence if it defines
a perfect matching between the elements
of its domain set and the elements of
its output set we call such functions by
ejections or isomorphisms so the reason
I'm so interested in this idea of a
bijective function or a one-to-one
correspondence that guarantees that
every element of one set gets matched
with an element of the other set no
matter how many elements there are these
bijections or these one-to-one
correspondences as they help
mathematicians reason about Infinity how
can you compare something that is
endless today we're going to think about
Infinity as a cardinality which is a
technical term for a number that could
be a size of a and we're going to use
this idea of one-to-one Correspondence
to try and investigate the question of
whether all infinite sets have the same
size so what I've drawn here are some
pictures of some of the infinite sets
that appear in mathematics so the
natural numbers are the prototypical
example of an infinite set so the
natural numbers are clearly a subset
of the integers both of these are
infinite sets are they the same size
infinity or different size Infinities I
guess the integers would there'd be more
integers than natural numbers I'm going
to now try and convince you that there
are in fact the same size infinity and
this is using this idea of a one-to-one
correspondence which was applied in this
context by Georg Cantor what he says is
if we can match up the elements of the
integers with the elements of the
natural numbers so that there's nothing
left over so that there's a bijective
function between them then that's a
proof that there's exactly as many
natural numbers as there are integers
start by matching zero with zero and one
with one but then we want to include the
negatives in the list so which natural
number would we match with negative one
maybe two maybe two why not because now
we're starting to make progress on
matching all the negatives we can match
the natural number three with the
integer two
the natural number four with the integer
minus two and do you see a pattern all
of the positive integers would be odd
numbers and all the negative integers
would be even numbers great so now I
have a much harder question so we have
the same challenge again evidently there
are way way way more rational numbers
than there are integers does that mean
there's a this is a larger infinite set
than the integers what do you think by
intuition I would say yes but that was
the same case with the integers I would
imagine there might be some bijective
function for mapping natural numbers to
rational numbers so I'm going to use
this picture to count the rational
numbers by actually counting the
elements of this larger set because
it'll be clearer geometrically what I've
drawn in this picture is the integer
lattice so Z Cross C refers to the set
of all of these dots so I'll start by
counting the number at the origin and
you can see I'm just labeling the dots
around the origin moving in a
counterclockwise fashion and getting
progressively further away
and this process could continue
but maybe by now you see the pattern
that would be a little bit difficult to
describe as a function oh is it for each
rational number there's a pair of
natural or integers that represent that
rational number yeah that's exactly
right and now for each pair of integers
I'm going to represent it by a
corresponding natural number that's
what's going on with this counting and
when I compose those operations what
I've done is I've encoded rational
numbers as natural numbers in a way that
reveals that they can be no larger there
are no more rational numbers than
natural numbers so this slope is
represented by 3 2 and 3 2 is in here as
25. exactly so that's exactly right so
we were hoping to compare the size of
Infinity of the rational numbers with
the size of Infinity of the natural
numbers so what we've done is introduced
an intermediate set these pair of
integer points and this proves that this
size of infinity is smaller than the
size of infinity since we also have an
injective function the other way this
size of infinity is smaller than this
size of infinity so therefore they must
be the same size that's wild
now there's one final collection of
numbers that we haven't yet discussed
which are the real numbers all of the
points on the number line
do you think that's the same size
Infinity I guess again intuition seems
like it must be much larger but
I don't know I haven't been on a roll
Dior Cantor proved that it is impossible
to count all real numbers like we've
just counted the rational numbers or
just counted the integers this is called
the cardinality of the Continuum is
uncountable what I'm going to do now is
form a new real number that I guarantee
is not on this list okay so here's how
we do this what I'm going to do is I'm
going to look at the diagonal elements
so I'll highlight them
this continues forever and now I'm going
to form a new real number by changing
all of these so if you just like added
one to them then that would be something
that doesn't exist in any of the other
ones yes you see the idea right away so
I'm going to form a new real number
whose first digit is different from this
one and you've already convinced
yourself that this number is not on this
list anywhere why is that because at
every Point there's at least one change
from a number in there
great that's exactly right so what we've
proven is that this number is missing
and therefore it is impossible to define
a bijection between the natural numbers
and the real numbers so we've started to
explore some of the counter-intuitive
properties of Infinity on the one hand
there are infinite sets that feel very
different like the natural numbers the
integers the rational numbers that
nevertheless have the same size or the
same infinite cardinality
well there are other infinities that are
larger so there's more than one size of
infinity not all infinities are created
equal I was wondering what the kind of
practical implications are what you can
do with this sort of knowledge really
glad you asked me that there's a
practical implication for computer
science Alan Turing he came up with a
mathematical model of a computer
something called a Terrain machine so
Turin was wondering is it possible to
compute every real number an arbitrary
real number to within arbitrary
Precision in finite time he defined a
real number to be computable if you
could calculate its value maybe not
exactly but as accurately as you'd like
in a finite amount of time and because
there are uncountably infinitely many
real numbers but only countably
infinitely many terrain machines what
that means is that the vast majority of
real numbers are uncomputable so we'll
never be able to access them with a
computer program
[Music]
you're a PhD student is that right yes
I'm a second year PhD student at the
University of Maryland does Infinity
come up in your mathematics that you're
studying one place Infinity comes up is
in algebraic geometry normally we think
okay well if you have two lines like
this you'd keep drawing them well the
intersite right here but in projective
space two parallel lines will also
intersect at the point at infinity
infinity is like this perfect concept
for what we can add to a space that
allows lines to have this more uniform
property what's your research in so one
of my main research areas is something
called category Theory that's been
described as the mathematics of
mathematics it's a language that can be
used to prove very general theorems and
an interesting aspect of being a
researcher in category theory that
doesn't come up as much in other areas
is that we have to really pay attention
to the axioms of set theory in our work
when you're approving theorems have you
ever used the Axiom of choice yeah it's
basically this idea that you can put a
choice function on any set and a choice
function does what exactly yeah that's a
good question so the way I think about
it is if you have an infinite or an
arbitrary family of sets and you know
for sure that none of these sets are
empty then a choice function would allow
you to select an element from each set
sort of all at once when you've used the
Axiom of choice in proofs you know which
incarnation of this you've used yeah
I've used it like that I've also used it
in Zorn Zama and in the well ordering
principle so there are three well-known
famous equivalent forms of the axing of
choice the well-ordering principle is
the Assumption the Axiom that any set
can be well ordered but there are lots
of subsets of real numbers that do not
have a minimal element so that ordering
is not a well ordering so here's the key
question do you believe the Axiom of
choice I do believe The Accidental
choice you do believe the eczema choice
though it leads us to some strange
conclusions so if the Axiom choice is
true then it's necessarily the case that
there exists a well ordering of the real
and what that means is that we can
perform induction over real numbers like
we perform induction over the natural
numbers this is trans-finite induction
it would work for any ordinal so there
must be some uncountably infinite
ordinal that represents the order type
of the real numbers and this allows us
to prove some crazy things imagine
three-dimensional euclidean space so the
space that we live in extending
infinitely in all directions so it is
possible to completely cover
three-dimensional euclidean Space by
disjoint circles so infinitesimal
circles disjoint Circles of radius one
so what that means is you can put a
circle somewhere in space and then put a
second Circle somewhere in space that
can't intersect with the first one
because these are you know solid circles
and then another Circle and somehow
cover every single point in space with
no gaps that's crazy yeah it's crazy
it's not the only crazy thing do you
have a favorite consequence of the Axiom
of choice I mean the bonoctarsky Paradox
is a big one so basically it says that
you can using just rigid motions I think
you can take one ball a solid ball with
a finite volume yeah cut it up and then
rearrange the pieces so that in the end
you get two balls which are the exact
same size the exact same volume so
you've actually taken one thing and
using just pretty normal operations to
it you can double it which seems pretty
implausible in real life right that
seems crazy to me and yet it's
irrefutable consequence of this Axiom
that you tell me you believe is true
yeah so how many infinities are there
well definitely uncountably many
infinities right so there's no there's
certainly no stop to this procedure but
could you give a precise cardinal
quality to that probably not because if
I could there would be a set of all sets
right so cantor's diagonal argument can
be abstracted and then generalized to
prove that for an arbitrary set a its
power set has a strictly larger
cardinality and since that's true for
any set we can just iterate this process
when set theory was being discovered or
invented or created in the late 19th
century one of the natural question to
ask is can there be a universe of all
sets this comes up in my research in
category Theory because even though
there is no set of all sets we would
really like for there to be a category
of so what category theorists need to do
to make their work rigorous is to add
additional axioms to set theory one of
my favorites was introduced by an
algebraic geometer Alexander growthendik
this is something that we sometimes call
a growth indicate Universe they're also
an inaccessible Cardinal it's an
infinite number that is so big that it
cannot be accessed by any of the other
constructions within set theory it's so
big that we'll never get to it and this
allows us to contemplate the
collection of all sets whose cardinality
is bounded by this size that will never
reach so you're just making a cutoff
Point you're saying we're never going to
get sets bigger than this anyway so we
might as well make our category only
include things lower smaller than that
that's right so a rigorous way to work
with a category of sets is to demand
that it's a category of sets whose size
is bounded by this cardinality Alpha say
that is then an example of a category
that fits into another even still larger
growth in geek Universe beta so
implicitly in a lot of my research I
have to add an additional assumption
that there exists maybe accountably many
inaccessible Cardinals
examples of infinite sets abound in
mathematics you know we see them every
day so do those Infinities exist I think
you'll get a different answer from every
person every mathematician you meet it
is a construct so it exists in the same
way that things like that like the
Poetry exists when you talk about
even cardinality and it's just like well
here's an infinite Hotel I had one
student who was like no no no
it's not that does not exist when I
describe like well imagine you do this
infinitely many times they're done with
me because they're like I can't no one
can do this infinitely many times right
these interesting paradoxes that come
from like the ape typing in a typewriter
and eventually getting to Hamlet is an
example of like well if you give
something forever and any random event
is going to happen it can be generative
yeah sure it's definitely a really
interesting really interesting thing to
try to talk to students about I mean
I'll grant you that Hilbert's Hotel does
not exist for me infinite objects
absolutely exist and I can't read the
thoughts in your head but I have a high
degree of confidence that we have a lot
of the same ideas about Infinity it's
this idea that are things that you can
think of do they exist getting into
philosophy of math now which is exciting
I mean I think that's another common
misconception about mathematics is that
it's so far removed from the humanities
for instance I mean it's hard to ignore
some of these philosophical questions
particularly when we're talking about
certain certain things like infinity and
I think one of the most difficult things
to really be precise about and to
explain to students is the Continuum
hypothesis what do you say to students
about the Continuum hypothesis the most
fun thing to teach when you teach about
Infinity when students realize that you
are talking about different sizes of
Infinity but then a natural thing is for
them to think about like what is the
next size of infinity that I can think
about and sort of the Continuum
hypothesis is sort of one of these
really hard things to grasp so what's so
fascinating about the Continuum
hypothesis is you take a subset of the
real line that's infinite does it
necessarily have either the cardinality
of the naturals or the cardinality of
Continuum or is there some sort of third
possibility what's very surprising is
the Continuum hypothesis has been
complete completely resolved in the
sense that we now know for absolute
certain that we will never know whether
it's true or false so this is a little
bit confusing the standard foundational
axioms of mathematics that we take for
granted are completely insufficient to
prove the Continuum hypothesis one way
or the other you know mathematicians
among other things have been very clear
about exactly what they're taking as an
assumption and exactly what they're
concluding from it so mathematical
practices to be exactly transparent
about the hypotheses you need to prove
your theorem so now I think of a proof
of a theorem more like constructing a
function where the domain of that
function is all of the hypotheses that
I'm assuming and then the target of that
function is maybe a particular element
in some universe that is the moduli
space of the statement that I'm trying
to prove or something like this if the
foundations were to change if set theory
were replaced by something else maybe
dependent type Theory do you think the
theorems you've proven would still be
true there's a lot of math that we sort
of take for granted as this is the thing
that you can do without really admitting
that we are
creating the foundations that are the
basis for the work we do later and so
yes I think that if we change the
foundations we would change mathematics
but I think that's also very humbling in
that it's not that we're sort of
discovering a universal truth is we're
humans constructing meaning right it's
abstract art in a sense there is
something there even if you can't see
all the pieces for particular things and
I think that's really fascinating I was
thinking about this on the drive here
the way that I interact with infinity I
mentioned earlier is is sometimes we in
number Theory especially we say well
does this type of equation have
infinitely many solutions and then you
know the question is is are there
infinitely many are there not or like
you know are there infinitely money twin
primes these are sort of interesting
ideas but I don't think that knowing if
it's infinite or not is necessarily the
most interesting thing for me what's
been most interesting to me is all the
math that gets developed to be able to
answer that question giving current
technology and who knows what
mathematics will look like in 100 years
150 years ago when we barely knew
infinity and look where we are today
yeah
Infinity inspires me to imagine a world
that is so much broader than what I'll
ever experience with my senses or over
the span of a human life the ideas can
just go on and on and on forever